Try by day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
T mobile arena reserves for Mayweather,
Mcgregor,
good sibling.
It's fucking happening.
How is that going to happen?
What do you mean how you think?
Do you think the UFC and may were there come to an agreement?
Yes.
That's what's happening
is in coach with the UFC.
Let's get,
I can't hear you as he's involved,
but the report,
who knows who,
who made that report?
Pretty lucky.
Did you get it on the way over here?
I Made A.
I might have.
I think it's going to happen,
man.
Wow.
You really think so.
I really do.
And you're asking me to come to own it.
So let's just figure this out.
Now you want to talk to you?
Just what do you do to probably companion?
Oh Man,
I don't know man.
I don't know what I'm doing.
While if you're not commentating,
we need you like giant companion for it and celebrate the shit out of it.
I would prefer that.
Honestly,
June 10th June 10th it's about to get a lot of my man may whether throws you
that TMT money.
I don't think they really care about me commentating.
They'd probably want Max Kellerman or of the boxing people.
Max Kellerman you boom.
It would be fun.
I would love to do it with them.
But that's what I,
that's,
that's a boxing match,
you know,
that's their world.
Even if it was him and a manager though and he was sitting down next to me doing
commentary,
you know that I think that would be a little odd to not a Floyd was just doing
boxing the octagon.
You know what I'm saying?
You need to be an awesome,
well no,
no I'm saying if,
if the roles were reversed,
I think you could talk about moving Connor's history cause they,
they're not going to know shit.
Let's be right.
They're going to be like,
you know Shannon Sharpe talking about UFC,
it's tough to listen to.
It's going to be good at on who's knowledgeable breakdown like commerce history,
how he came here.
He got his movement,
what he's known for.
I think that's super important.
You have to forgive people who don't watch UFC.
Yeah.
Cause you're getting a shit load of new boxing.
You know,
it sounds fast.
Tune in,
hanging out with you guys.
Smoking weed,
watching it right here.
That sounds so much better.
I just want my dear friend Joe Rogan,
part of the biggest fight of combat and history.
I'm good.
Like it's a big deal right here.
Cause you don't think that's the biggest fight in his life.
Fighting history bigger than Ali Frazier.
Yes.
Number wise.
Yeah.
It's the biggest,
biggest paper view ever because it brings in two worlds.
It brings in the UFC world and this one guy who was unquestionably the biggest
star in the UFC,
unquestionably by a long shot.
And then you bring in a guy who has been one of the biggest moneymakers in the
history of boxing,
changed the game.
The only guy to go 49 and no others in rocky Marciano.
I mean he's like right there and we'd love to break rocky Marciano's record.
And then you know what,
man,
when people want to do things like break someone's record and you want to do it
so bad that you take on a guy who's never had a boxing match before and then
that guy starches,
you
know saying,
I mean it's not like does that,
I'm going to build a shrine to him,
pray to whatever this summer I'm going to get a tattoo.
Man.
I'm telling you,
there's something about that dude.
He's got something going on.
Magic.
He's got a little something extra special,
but he would need,
he would everything to line up.
It would have to be the McGregor Mayweather would have to dismiss him as a
threat.
He'd have to not train hard enough.
He'd have to not seriously consider the possibility that Connor connects on him
and knocks him out.
Right.
And then Connor would have to do some rough housing.
He would have to hold him.
He'd have to hold them and hit 'em.
You'd have to try to get off as many shots and bullying around and wear him out.
It's a possibility.
He's a much bigger mass.
He's a much quicker manner.
Yeah,
very,
very quick.
But if you compare the two of them frame wise,
like what if they ever do do it and they're standing right at each other looking
down at each other,
you know,
do an eye to eye,
you're going to go,
oh shit.
Yeah.
Connor's way.
Because you remember when Eddie Alvarez was going Idi with Connor and you
realize how big Connor's head is.
He'll like Jesus,
we're just a bigger dude.
Cause from shoulders,
his legs,
he's a big fuck.
I mean he could make that 145 pound cut when he was on death's door,
but may,
whether it makes it easy,
what are they going to fight at 45 that's a good question.
No,
maybe there was fighting at one 54 is like wow,
I bet they do it like 55 or 60 maybe.
Maybe.
Depends on what may was comfortable with,
but,
but I think the,
and Dana White,
you want to be part of that fight.
If you're Dana let you want to be in cahoots with all these guys with
Mayweather,
Floyd,
or you don't want the fight to take place at all and book he's got fuck because
number Grumet off,
got sick,
making that weight.
If number get Madoff didn't get sick,
making that weight,
then Neuroma Madoff and Tony Ferguson,
Dana White did.
Oh No,
doc did because look,
the real fight is the winner of,
uh,
Tony Ferguson and Habib number good metal in the UFC.
Right.
So that's the real fight is like being a big challenge for Conor.
And that could be a million plus paper.
Right?
It's basically,
if you,
if you either have that fight or the better fight financially is another fight
with Nate Diaz.
No,
the better fight financially is may with Oh yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
Connor has a business that's by far the 100% agree with you.
What I was saying in 20 million,
way more than a hundred million or a hundred by a hundred.
100 million each.
Lloyd to Ray Borg looks good as far as he does.
He's so fast.
Okay.